daniel lessard à tahoua emmanuelle
latraverse à montréal michel ces ogm ont
rien messieurs dames bonsoir à vous
parfois je veux pas en faire tout un
plat parce que bon attendre 20 22
minutes une heure est pas la fin du
monde non plus pour aller voter entre
vous me direz ce que vous en pensez mais
manifestement on a été un peu débordé
par cette demande c'est du jamais vu là
il ya eu 1 6 million en deux jours on
n'a pas les chiffres deviennent
aujourd'hui évidemment un daniel voté
par anticipation cette viande mode là je
suis allé hier patrice au milieu
d'après-midi en disant ça va se faire
rapidement une quinzaine de personnes
devant moi ça a pris presque une heure
pour me présenter devant le scrutateur
et j'ai dû le faire en anglais parce que
ça se passait en anglais seulement
écoutez il ya tout un processus il faut
biffer le nom sur la liste et les
épaisses comme ça ça prend du temps à
trouver le nom il faut ensuite leur
écrire sur une feuille chercher ça on a
on a l'impression qu'on est encore là
dans une période préhistorique on a
oublié à élections canada qu'on ne fait
maintenant dans les nerfs de
technologies avancées
emmanuel mais je vois que élections
canada affirme finalement qu'ils sont
ils sont lille on l'aimé liés par les
règles de la loi électorale qui leur
empêche de plus de bureaux de vote
c'est comme si la machine d'élections
canada était pas prête à la réalité de
comment les partis politiques de putis
lisent le vote par anticipation
on en a parlé au cours des derniers
jours c'est plus l'occasion de faire
voter les gens qui seront plus là le
jour du vote tous les personnes âgées
c'est un outil de campagne électorale
maintenant les partis politiques mettent
une énergie monumental pour faire sortir
tout le vote qui leur est acquis et
c'est ce qui crée cette affluence une
soudaine qui prend la machine ont
définitivement une fois cette élection
passé peut-être qu'il faudra encore une
fois ouvrir 7 mai michel je vous soumets
en même temps que l'élection c'est le 19
octobre
c'est pas une semaine c'est pas qu'on en
fasse pas à ce moment le scrutin lancé
si on veut pas
on a décidé qu'on voulait ouvrir c'est
au plus grand nombre d'électeurs
possibles au provincial au québec s'est
tellement passé dans les moeurs des
circonscriptions c'est 15% des électeurs
qui vont bureaux de vote avancé et y
attend pas deux heures et demie chaque
fois mais dans le kop mon ami daniel je
pense que c'est la ville de naissance
quel était le problème c'est benjamin de
bronze en anglais ok donc ils vont
s'ajuster un mobile le monsieur un peu
mais je le vois on verra pour la suite
et un aspect intéressant rapidement
patrice jean marc léger de léger
marketing
et hier c'est probablement aussi signe
d'une volonté importante de changement
j'imagine qui sait de quoi il parle
d'autres sondeurs disait la même chose
ce matin il y en a jamais eu autant
emmanuel on le disait tout à l'heure
moi je le voyais dans le quartier j'ai
essayé d'y aller - ce midi je vais pas
c'est avec gens viennent au bureau et
j'ai pas pu je vais retourner ce soir
pietro faire comme moi il faut voter par
la poste j'aime l'idée là de mettre le
expédia les puits le cérémonial
ok je vais vous faire écouter quelque
chose on n'écoute pas ce que c'est
croire voilà s'il venait à peu mise en
scène pour dire aux contribuables ce que
selon lui à des hausses de taxes michel
ccd mise en scène que bon les
conservateurs nous ont habitués à ça là
on veut vraiment frappé l'imaginaire ce
que ça marche ça marche pas mais ça
marche on vient de le montrer la
bienvenue perd encore plus de gens qui
l'ont vu qu'avant qu'on le montre alors
mais cela dit monsieur harper dans le
rôle de l'animateur du price doit être
sûr que c'est un bon casting mais la
réalité c'est que on se dit je sais pas
si c'est le conseil australien du
premier ministre il ya dix ans on se dit
quand il faut frapper l'imaginaire on
est dans la dernière semaine
on semblait tartare donc le coaching est
là
sur la table en teck bas tout le monde
comprend que china et comme c'est très
inusité
ben tout le monde va le mettre au
bulletin de nouvelles ça soit vrai ou et
on a mis deux fois même emmanuel même si
elle m'a volé ma ligne ça n'a pas un nom
qui va accuser niche mais je voudrais
que ça fonctionne pas pour faire bouger
si vous voulez des pans entiers de
l'électorat mais dans tous les comtés
qui compte le plus en ontario ce que les
conservateurs tentent de défendre face
tout particulièrement aux libéraux on le
voit d'ailleurs c'est à la marge c'est
très très très serré en ce moment et
donc le pari des conservateurs c'est de
dire que ça peut être suffisant pour
sauver la mise dans quelques comptes et
on a souvent tourné en dérision les
tactiques décrite un peu comme grossière
des conservateurs vous rappellez
campagne contenant un collectif
constitué falzon c'est tellement gros
seins
la réalité c'est que pour eux ça porte
ses fruits auprès d'une frange
électrodes c'est celle qui doit garder
en stock ou et les impôts monsieur
daniel puis l'argent ça ça touche tout
le monde faut il faut qu'il soit
crédible dans son message mais ça ça
touche tout le monde ouais sauf que sauf
que l'étranger qui est débarqué au
canada ce matin donc premier contact
avec la télévision a été cette semaine
et s'est sûrement dit inondé drôle de
façon de faire des élections ces
canadiens âgés jusqu'à ce matin moi je
pensais que les conservateurs étaient
encore en très bonne position pour
gagner cette élection
sephora qui je suis peut-être cela le
faire mais on sous-estiment toujours le
vote conservateur de deux ou trois
points je me disais que braquant gagner
après avoir vu cette scène je me suis et
l'impression qu'ils sont inquiets fait
pression qu'elle avance de trudeau les
déranger l'impression qu'ils vont tout
faire cette semaine pour le démolir
est ce que c'est la bonne façon c'est
quoi ce lagarde la société des alcools
la modération est toujours meilleur goût
mais justement mais je vais faire ce que
ce que vous dites daniel on va écouter
un extrait de justin trudeau
cette fois ci et ça monte là il ya
peut-être quelque chose qui a chargé
dans cette campagne on écoute les
conservateurs ne sont pas nos ennemis
ils sont nos voisins nos cousins et nos
oncles hymne aux parents ils sont nos
amis comme nous ils veulent ce qu'il ya
de mieux pour leur pays
ils veulent des communautés sécuritaires
pour leurs enfants
et une économie forte ils veulent un
pays qui se tient debout sur la scène
mondiale et qui défend fièrement nos
valeurs
rêvons pas besoin de convaincre de les
convaincre d'abandonner le parti
conservateur
nous devons juste leur démontrer que
c'est le parti de stephen harper qui les
a abandonnés
est-ce que justin trudeau a fait le
plein des libéraux a fait assez mal ou
npd là il s'attaque au batteur
conservateur daniel way et c'est habile
il n'y a pas de doute là dessus
ce qu'il va devoir faire cette semaine
c'est de rester au-dessus de la mêlée de
montrer que contrairement à michael
ignatieff stéphane dion lui ne sont pas
capables de le démolir
qui dit bien au dessus tout ça qu'il est
même capable de courtiser les électeurs
conservateurs à sauf que là les attaques
vont être fortes vont être virulente à
ce ne sera pas facile de ce moment des
libéraux comme on s'inquiétait à ya
sûrement des néo-démocrates aussi qu'on
voudrait bien voir aller chez des
libéraux pour lui permettre de gagner
facilement qu'ils vont te dire
peut-être qu'on est mieux de rester où
on est mais à c'est certain que ça va
être très dur pour justin trudeau cette
semaine des conservateurs mondial
affrontera emmanuel quand vous avez
entendu cet appel là parce que l'appel
vis-à-vis les électeurs du npd a déjà
été fait me le moteur reprises l'a
d'ailleurs ils sont programmés plus à
gauche presque celui du npd l'aï dit aux
gens conservateurs c'est correct là où
vous êtes des bonnes personnes peuvent
venir chez nous là vous savez depuis le
congrès du parti libéral à montréal il
ya deux ans et demi une phrase alain
terme c'est sonny west
l'idée c'est que justin trudeau est
capable de faire campagne en étant au
dessus de la mêlée on le vit aussi dans
le ton de l'entrevue que donné à tout le
monde en parle hier lui ai dit monsieur
recruteurs son premier ministre monsieur
mulcair était son collègue même si tout
le monde avait compris qu'il aime pas
beaucoup c'est le ton qui veut garder
jusqu'à la fin de la campagne c'est la
seule façon pour lui une part de ne pas
se laisser embarquer si vous voulez dans
les attaques des conservateurs à son
égard ici que ça va être virulent dans
les prochains jours et c'est une façon
essayer de me montrer que lui ont pas
besoin de s'inquiéter
trop de ça parce qu'il est assis
confiant dans ses chances de gagner
donc si le ton qu'ils ont décidé
d'adopter d'où cette façon de lancer un
appel aux conservateurs sans justement
démolir alors vers les sites emmène mal
journée oui là michel c'est ça il
il a dit en ontario il existe plus
particulièrement nos thériault meilleurs
au canada des
progressistes-conservateurs des gens qui
étaient contactées les raids au risque
d'un déjà qui ont-ils voté conservateur
aux dernières élections mais qui sont
trouve des fois que monsieur aperam un
peu trop qui ne sont pas nécessairement
pour le fait de condamner le nu à chaque
fois que l'onu parle par exemple pour ne
pas avoir le kiki qui tiennent à une
meilleure place pour le canada dans le
monde ces raids toril assez
progressistes conservateurs
il peut aller en chercher un certain
nombre et c'est ce qui était écrit cette
fois puis d'autre part belle quand on
est un conservateur qui on voit le chef
libéral personnes risquent d'être encore
plus énervé peut-être de faire des
gaffes parce que une semaine c'est court
mais ça peut être long daniel vous
parliez d'un tacle très très dur ce pas
terminer cette histoire là quand même là
daniel j'entends tout une conversation
de la régie dans les oreilles vous ai
perdus de vue des minutes fut d injecter
ces cours une semaine mais ça peut être
long aussi on va voir si les
conservateurs comme vous dites qu'ils
ont le sang commence à voir monsieur
trudeau monte trop là ils vont vraiment
aller le tout pour le tout le tout
l'objectif des conservateurs c'est de
faire trébucher c'est de le faire sortir
de ses gonds c'est de montrer qu'il est
pro prêt à gouverner les publicités
originales n'ont peut-être pas atteint
leur but on va revenir à la charge
seul adversaire c'est trudeau sera peu
vont pas perdre beaucoup de temps avec
vous je 17 ou avec le mans le coeur très
bien emmanuel et
chelsea les conservateurs ont commencé
la campagne en faisant d'eux en tant que
justin trudeau n'était pas prêt hélas
comme il a survécu aux dix premières
semaines siro c'est une partie du
discours qu'on entend plus de leur côté
accusé les libéraux de vouloir aussi les
taxes les impôts est une terrasse ça
fait des semaines aussi que les
conservateurs le dise donc un risque
pour eux a plu frappe sur le cloud puis
envoie aussi le message aux canadiens
qu'ils sont eux mêmes en difficulté face
à lui ils ont fait dix semaines qui
disent ça se peut pas que trudeau fasse
pas une grosse gaffe le npd disait la
même chose et secrète match sûr que le
black vous la même chose ça se peut pas
qu'il fasse pas nuire aux gaffes sas
pour moi que ça continue il y c'est
l'histoire de la campagne c'est ça c'est
là où justin trudeau de vin tribu
chebeya pas trébucher et les attentes on
le disait au départ d'ailleurs est un
stratège conservateur qui s'en veut
encore pour la blague qui a fait mais
les attentes
quand il dit s'il arrive avec ses
pantalons au premier des votes rudeau ça
sera déjà dépassé les attentes mais bref
les attentes c'est vrai qu'elle était
plus basse pour monsieur trudeau on a
sous-estimé on a sous-estimé beaucoup
moi le premier et plusieurs de mes
collègues aussi l'opposition en se
disant bon c'est vous quelqu'un comme
moi je vais aller jusqu'à dire c'est pas
le père pour avoir couvert le père
pendant cinq ans et avoir suivi les
flots de votre père qui souvent qu'à mon
tour je me disais bon ce gentil garçon
et des ferments une bonne tête tête de
rockstar il ya peut-être des gens qui
vont aimer ça mais en bout de piste il
fera pas le poids vis-à-vis des deux ans
il a fait le poids vis-à-vis des autres
et aujourd'hui il reste très peu de
temps et à thomas mulcair et surtout à
stephen harper pour montrer qu'il n'est
pas prêt à gouverner
voilà messieurs dames on a les nouveaux
chiffres on à la journée d'hier qui
s'ajoute la 760 5000 de plus d'électeurs
qui sont allés voter donc total pour les
trois jours
2,4 millions c'est une augmentation de
16% par rapport à 2011 et ya pas la
journée d'aujourd'hui
donc c'est une journée aujourd'hui
ces courges évidemment alors bon voilà
les gens voter et on verra ce que ça
donne pour le taux de participation
le designer parce que la dernière fois
souvenez vous c'est à 61% s'était pas
beaucoup non c'est pas beaucoup au
québec traditionnellement c'est moins
élevés au fédéral qu'au provincial
mais quand même 60 c'est un ordre de
grandeur en dessous là alors il faudra
voir et comme dit emmanuel c'est tout à
fait vrai les sondeurs le disent tout le
temps quand il ya une grosse
participation d'habitude lorsque les
gens veulent faire le ménage ils veulent
se débarrasser du gouvernement
alors on verra si c'est ce qui se passe
lundi soir prochain
très bien merci à vous trois dernières
têtes les gens qui vous parlait c'était
le sait le scrutateur qui vous demander
votre salon qui vont certainement od qui
est sûrement charmante mais bon j'aurais
préféré l'entendre on la connaît pas on
la salue du sida montréal